today we're talking about the gta
trilogy getting de-listed fortnite
getting easier refunds and possibly an
among us crossover and league of legends
is disabling all chat my name is devante
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
let's start with a reminder that the gta
trilogy will be taken off digital
shelves this week so if you want to buy
the original gta 3 vice city and san
andreas you might want to scoop that up
probably by the end of today news of the
d listing came last week after rockstar
games officially announced a new grand
theft auto remaster package featuring
all three games gta trilogy the
definitive edition will be available on
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x and s
nintendo switch and pc through the
rockstar games launcher later this year
and feature updated and improved
versions of all three games a mobile
edition for ios and android is coming in
the first half of 2022 and pricing was
not announced
now let's talk about some fortnite news
when epic introduced fortnite imposters
mode over the summer some people
criticized the game for lifting so much
from indie darling among us including
inner sloth the game's tiny team that
felt blindsided by fortnite's new mode
but now it looks like epic and
intersloth may be on good terms and the
two are even teasing a collaboration for
tonight's update 18.20 patch notes
include direct mentions of among us in
inner sloth and then the two companies
were seen chatting openly on twitter in
an exchange surely meant to turn heads
in it the two agree to collaborate on
something in the future which likely
means a more formal agreement has been
made in private so what could this be
among us skins in fortnite or the
opposite i guess we'll have to wait to
find out in the meantime let's talk
about how fortnite is making it easier
for you to get your money back
sorta
so remember how you used to have a
limited number of lifetime returns well
that's no longer the case fortnite
refund tickets are now available up to
three times per year and each one
refreshes individually in your account
365 days after it was used each refund
request must also be placed on an item
you purchased within the last 30 days
and only apply to item shop cosmetics so
they remain unavailable for battle
passes battle pass levels and loot
llamas within save the world mode still
it's good to know that you're not stuck
with a skin if you've changed your mind
about it refunds will always come in the
form of v-bucks not your local currency
so you'll still want to find something
else to buy or gift in the future
but okay let's switch gears to another
competitive multiplayer game league of
legends in a blog post it was revealed
that upcoming patch 11.21 will disable a
long time feature in matchmade cues all
chat riot is citing a rise in reports of
abuse over the past year as the reason
for the change all chat allows players
on both teams to type messages to one
another for everyone in the game to see
as you could imagine this often can
devolve into name calling and abuse
directed at the opposite team or
specific players which isn't exactly a
welcoming environment while riot
acknowledges that all chat isn't always
bad and can sometimes result in fun
interactions between teams the developer
says right now the bad out weighs the
good wright acknowledges that team chat
is often a source of abuse as well but
is keeping the function enabled as it
can play an important role in team
coordination
but alright even though riders
republic's release is right around the
corner you can try it out today for free
via ubisoft connect on pc
so if you missed out on the beta or you
had a lot of fun and just want to play
more early like me then make sure you
jump in today before it's too late
but alright hit the comments and let me
know what you really want from this
fortnite and among us possible
collaboration mixing of the the games
and
i don't know what i'm saying i don't
know what i'm saying
you